[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous partons sur l'idée du thème de
renaître et vous allez devoir essayer de
faire renaître cette expression qui
circulent dans la photo vous avez devant
vous l'aï les 40 on va dire à 50 il faut
que votre portrait y soit terminé
[Musique]
j'ai choisi deux de mes amis à dessiner
parce que bah je les connaissais du coup
ça me rassure et un peu à dessiner le
fait de connaître les personnes est de
savoir comment les décrire si j'avais
pris une personnalité c'est le public
pas je les connais pas donc à dessiner
et faire retranscrire un caractère ou
des émotions j'ai pas comment elles sont
dans leur vie et c'est donc c'était plus
simple pour moi d'avoir mes amis
[Musique]
c'est intéressant c'est que quand on
dessine quelque chose surtout un visage
on perçoit différentes émotions qu'on
percevait pas juste en regardant au
premier coup d'oeil un visage et au fil
des dessins apprend à apercevoir des
très bons on n'avait pas forcément
remarqué au début donc c'est une sorte
de renaissance
moi j'ai essayé de le dessiner de
manière
différente de d'habitude et mais
toujours avec la même énergie que
j'essaie de mettre dans mes dessins et
de pas forcément faire trop attention ou
proportions et l exactitude des trèfles
là pour le coup c'est renaître
d'une manière plastique montceau
on va dans un premier temps lorsqu'on
regarde les personnes on peut capter
différentes émotions aux différentes
choses
chaque nouveau dessin il faut
réapprendre à dessiner un portrait qui
est tout le temps le même et avec des
techniques du coup différente eh ouais
je dirais que ce serait ça pourra
renaître
[Musique]
de la cette sensation qu'ils ont compris
que un portrait
une personne c'est une expression une
personnalité une atmosphère et une
énergie vivante
c'est hyper intéressant parce que ça
nous ça nous aide à lâcher un peu sur la
technique et/ou et faire plus dans
l'impulsion à partir de rien créer
quelque chose et à prendre petit à petit
dans dans l'élan
il ya une expression intéressants qui
sont des gages de la ligne très beau
travail au fusain là avec plein de
subtilités des lignes épaisses et des
lignes fines ça avec des lignes très
fine contraste en fait des deux très
intéressant ça ça peut être réutilisé
dans d'autres des sens très bien